I met him at Burning you met of course
you did
you do you facilitate iasa trips what's
your I grow you grow
iasa do we have any dog owners in the
front room yeah okay so what's your dog
called Roa Roa that's a silly name that
ruins my theory Roa not not R Roa Roa
that's
it's red in Spanish I apologize for my
innate racism there for being like what
a silly name but really as a British man
I feel like what else could I have
said is it is it a red setter is it a
red dog of any sort Pitbull a pitbull oh
[__] do you have kids we used to yeah
um scary dogs aren't they they're very
sweet it's as you know everyone knows
pitbulls are actually good dogs it's
only the owners who make them bad so if
you got if you got a bad dog it's cuz
the person who has the dog so I'm sure
Roo is very lovely and has never
snatched off a toddler's
face he used to he used to be called
Blanco but then
uh in England we don't learn Spanish but
I I picked that one up
so it was either that or Gringo I think
they both mean the same
thing Roa Roa the Pitbull that's very
cool um may may I inquire us to your
name yeah Jenna Jenna hey but you have
so you're not Spanish but you have a
sexy
accent from here you're from here I I
know but which
bit oh yeah i' never have heard of it
New Hope Pennsylvania that is that's a
real [__] you can tell we got off the
shits we just walked around a bit and
we're like New Hope
Pennsylvania and then they went a bit
further and they were like lots of
people shoot shooting us with arrows
Pennsylvania um what uh what did you do
Jen oh my God it's clearly not as
hilarious as you think it is it's always
like oh my God she works in
HR I'm building a Sci-Fi Universe you're
building a Sci-Fi universe that is
laughable that is laughable well well I
mean look I would have expected that out
of this gentleman here
you oh what's the theme a it's like you
know if pirates met my
haircut what um look we can't we're not
enemies we got both got the same shoes
on haven't we um I'm going to take these
off now I don't want to be associated
with
your top knotted kind I'm still tall
don't
worry um what uh please don't steal them
they have custommade
insoles I'm doing well and I over
pronate [__] podiatrist in the back
there so you're building a Sci-Fi
Universe um for uh television or for
books or for video games com for video
games comics and nfts two years ago
people would have given a Big Woo at the
end of it and now they're like oh that's
sad that's the
big focus on the video games I reckon
and what's the what's the kind of vibe
of the I really feel weird being
barefooted on the stage I don't like it
I don't like it it feels very Laurel
Canyon
1960s what um what tell us give give us
the pressy of it unless it's an NDA yeah
okay uh it's called the wanders it's
called the wanders it's spy and like
kind of retro Spacey and retro original
and not to stamp on anyone's dreams or
anything that's very cool the wanderous
is Spacey retro and psychedelic CH very
excited when you were little when you
were a little girl growing up in New
Hope Pennsylvania what did you what did
you want to
be I don't know you don't know you just
fell into sci-fi World
building are you is it of your own
accord or is this man forcing
you produce
me it was I met him at Burning you met
of course you
did if you hadn't brought it up we all
would have assumed met a burning man and
then and then do you facilitate iasa
trips what's your the mild man an
accountant who on the weekends is like
no I am a
shaman grow you grow
[Applause]
iasa I mean like Po of people in the
front row and then a den of
inequity utter utter filth this is this
is the type of deviance for which I will
not
understand you sci-fi World Build and
Grow iasa you call your dog by a Spanish
name I mean do you have any tattoos of
course you do what are they triangle a
triangle where is it may I
ask because it grounds it's there
because it grounds
you it's the most structurally sound of
the
shakes any Engineers will know
wow did you did you tell the person
tattooing you that when you had it
done or you just like it's my favorite
shap I'm from
Pennsylvania would you like an
nft wow you met bur this is brilliant
this is this is all we need is it
okay Jen um let's get one final thing
what is uh where was your most wondrous
holiday where did you go for your most
wonderful
holiday like in in the world not like
internally when you were to the Amazon
you actually went there okay all right
uh DJ do me a favor let's do this let's
um we're going to celebrate Jen in all
her many
forms of which I'm sure there are many
and gentleman with the the beautiful
hair what's your name Emil are you
French
Swedish okay that's allowed it's spelled
slightly
[Music]
differently don't need to be rude yeah
you know we need this I'm not saying
you're an egyp you're just Swedish you
love the meatballs no fear I make it
clear this guy works at Ika he shaves
the hair at the sides top not high
spelling meal e m i with the L not the E
like the French language if you want to
go to burning man yeah will [__]
manage he can build you the camp bu you
the tent he works out for the week
before getting tense looking so Hench
make sure it's freshly shaved he just
founded himself like oh yesterday I'm
the Swedish guy better than the rest you
can see me on Sesame Street like I am
the chef saying dirty Hy goo ABA yo
that's what we do but we're moving on to
you the king of all men like the pirate
hair do but we focus on Jen one thing
she's after grow in iasa do it in
apartments yeah that's a disaster of
course you can't live in Manhattan you
wouldn't have the square footage that
you need to have it happen and you go to
New Hope Pennsylvania You' got a whole
farmyard acres and Acres just Fields as
far as you can see iasa from the vine or
the tree or the leaves or however it's
made I'm quite a stew I know you've got
to mash it up blend in the RO and this
guy he goes down to the Jungle he says
yes we'll make ourselves humble and
grounded we'll go down understand you
all what's this tattoo it's a tri
angle one two three side like a pyramid
cuz it's got a large base like a beat
that we're playing here it's got a large
base never wasting this when you go down
below you're like oh ho ho I'm really
tripping I know the future I can see I
scratched that I was picturing nfts and
that's down the it didn't go well but
this sci-fi thing holy hell yes I'm
pretty sure I can call it Wanderers did
you say Wanderers or wonders it doesn't
even matter I just keep rapping when I'm
on it take the IAS then I'm suddenly
vomit vomit vomit vomit yes it's so
thrilling tripping off my balls when I
World building oh it's Retros
psychedelic of course it is the kids
love it when they see the trip is
rewarding you come back from the Amazon
jungle you back up here see a mil you
like some of all us having fun that's
what we do you're outside there in
nature with you and what you got by your
side your best friend it's Roo he be
there like I int 10 my name's [__]
red it's from Spanish you thought I
Disappeared you thought that I would
vanish but I'll be here yes I'm so
cheerful call me the Pitbull I used to
be white in the face but now I spit all
the toddler on R ho no even knowing you
were probably the hero that's the
wandering dog for Jen and Emil that's
how he
[Music]
feel
w